karim pakzad bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
l'armée américaine on l'a vu c'est une
présence en irak mais aussi en
afghanistan
hier matin une dizaine de civils ont été
tués dans un nouvel attentat c'est le
vice-président afghan connu pour son
hostilité envers les talibans qui était
d'ailleurs visé la situation est donc
toujours très attendu dans le pays
comment le départ des soldats américains
et il vêtu à la fois par les autorités
le peuple afghan aujourd'hui avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'interrogations au
moins mais avec un certain peur et
inquiétude parce qu au départ des
soldats américains en afghanistan
[Musique]
nous ne se situe pas dans la même
condition qu en irak en afghanistan ce
départ qui d'ores et déjà commencé et
les cieux à l'essieu d'une guerre longue
maintenant de guerre entre les
américains et les talibans et que
finalement les américains n'ont pas
réussi à gagner cette guerre donc par
conséquence ce sont les temps les
banques sur le plan militaire ont gagné
cette guerre à la suite de cela il ya eu
des négociations de paix de paix entre
les américains et les temps les banques
d'où le traité à vaughan légale a été
exclu totalement et donc cela montre est
exactement de la nature de cette guerre
qui était non seulement entre au
gouvernement en place et c'est
d'opposant mais que c'était
une guerre entre une puissance étrangère
et les temps les bandes qui était au
pouvoir jusqu'à l'ère aimé des
américains et donc cela la population
parce que les gens sont alliés est de
chico à la suite de ces négociations
puis à londres les temps le mans vont
revenir au pouvoir et de fico personne
n'a confiance aux hôtes à des bandes
les gens pensent que nous d'échanger en
ce qui concerne leur comportement leur
écurie leur façon de voir la politique
la société la place des mains
extérieures
c'est la raison pour laquelle voilà le
retrait américain
on a connaissance une source
d'inquiétude
mais voilà on ira qu'il a il ya aussi un
le départ des troupes prévu en irak
comment il est perçu la barre on se
souvient le parlement avait demandé
l'exclu l'expulsion des troupes
américaines
c'est en janvier trois jours après
l'assassinât à bagdad du général iranien
soleymani alors du coup comment est-ce
qu'il est perçu ce départ aujourd'hui on
ira avec cette fois oui en fait si le
retrait américain d'irak n'a pas le même
qu'à te coller rentrer en afghanistan
néanmoins
ce retrait également est perçu comme un
échec pour des états unis les états unis
hualan clairement nos scores en 2003 a
envahi l'irak à un moment donné plus de
cent cinquante mille soldats américains
stationnés en irak lorsque barack obama
a décidé à la suite de refuser de les
autorités de bagdad d'or connaître
l'extra trait aux réalités des loi
américain sur les lois et la tient à son
moulin bas comme en été obligé de
retirer dans trente de ses soldats et
par la suite au moment où l'état
islamique coupé mousse où les grands
partis de nord de l'irak une grande
partie de la syrie que dans le cadre
d'une coalition internationale contre le
terrorisme tous les amis qu'à son roman
hume est en négociation avec le pouvoir
central irakien
il a mise en place est une
après une 14ème de base militaire en
irak
mais par la suite d'un but tout une fois
la menace dirait militaires de l'état
islamique disparu et cela grâce
grâce au combat comme monnaies les
forces militaires irakiennes avec les de
la mobilisation populaire
ce qu'on appelle en occident comme
démissionne aaa à partir de là la
présence américaine a pris une autre
forme car les divergences entre les
américains et les iraniens viennent de
se greffer sur la situation en irak et
l'irak est devenu un champ de rivalités
entre les états unis et l'arabie
séoudite d'un côté et l'iran de l'autre
côté et j'avais très bien
karim pakzad qu'on arrive vraiment au
terme de cette édition il nous reste
juste quelques secondes juste cette
dernière question en quelques mots ce
nouveau retrait intervient à quelques
semaines de la présidentielle pour vous
est-ce que c'est un hasard du calendrier
très brièvement s'il vous plaît non pas
du tout rires et mon adresse en 2004 et
en irak mais pas un hasard de l'autre on
sait que ce retrait est très populaire
parmi ses électeurs
même si ce n'est par colère chez les
états-majors de l'armée mais populaire
chez les électeurs
c'est l'heure à laquelle et puis ils
vont éviter une une tension du début
serait sur une guerre entre les
etats-unis et l'iran en grains merci
beaucoup karim pakzad d'avoir répondu à
deux questions je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur associé à l'iris spécialiste
de l'afghanistan de l'iran et de l'irak